I really love lost stories.
So I'm from this very tiny, hot island
in the middle of the Caribbean
called Nassau.
Has anyone here ever heard of it?
Yeah?
I distinctly remember the place
being so small that I could land there,
shout from the airport,
my brothers would somehow hear me
and they would know
to come and pick me up.
(Laughter)
The North Pole, however,
is an inhospitable frozen tundra
that's incredibly difficult to get to.
Not to surprise any of you,
but I am the first Bahamian presumably
to set foot on the North Pole.
(Applause)
It's true.
Now, if you were to speak to my parents
about what I was like growing up,
they would tell you
that I was mischievous, precocious,
the kid devouring all the information
and never, ever taking a no for an answer.
But if you got them into a secret room,
they would also tell you that I was
a pain in the butt and a troublemaker.
Early in my practice,
it was important for me
to create an artwork
that would share the sense of vastness
that I'd experienced in the Arctic
with my community.
So on a second expedition,
I decided to move
this 4.5-ton piece of ice
from this frozen Arctic river
and bring that to my neighborhood.
(Laughter)
I'd work with a team
of scientists and engineers,
and together we would install
this block of ice
in a solar-powered freezer unit
outside of my childhood classroom
on this 100-degree day.
Now, the response was a mix
of excitement and wonder.
The folks in my neighborhood
had never really seen ice quite like this.
It was my way of telling the story
of our deep connections to each other.
Now, while all of this was going on,
I realized I was having a separate
journey of discovery.
It was on this expedition
where I began to hear whispers
of an unknown polar explorer
named Matthew Henson.
Now, up until this point,
the fact that the first person
to set foot in the North Pole
looked like me, had me aghast.
I mean, come on, look at this guy.
(Laughter)
In 1909, Henson, and fellow
explorer Robert Peary,
had done what no others
had done up to that point.
They had made it to the North Pole.
Now, this son of a sharecropper
had managed over seven Arctic expeditions.
Yet his massive, massive contributions
became lost to history.
And I ain't really cool with that.
So since this lightning-bolt moment,
my work became a quest
to tell these lost stories.
And to tell all of you the truth,
if you really pay attention,
you start to see these
lost stories all around you.
And when you find them,
you realize that they can speak
with a very loud mouth.
Now growing up, my grandparents'
house was the place
where my entire Bahamian family would meet
every Sunday for Sunday dinner.
Now I've got a big family, so,
13 aunts and uncles and 52 cousins
would all squeeze
into my grandparents' tiny home.
And for sure the house was small,
but it was a sanctuary
filled with life and love.
Now, I believe I was around 12 years old
when my grandfather came home
with the first set of encyclopedias
in our community.
This was a big deal.
My uncles, who were some big dudes,
would never let us get close to these
books without wearing gloves, guys.
Can you all believe that?
I couldn't wait for my turn
to fan through these pages.
And as I would fan through these pages,
the questions would arrest me, like,
who wrote all of this,
and how did they write all of it?
And was everything in the entire universe
arrested in these pages?
And as I would fan
through this book further,
a question really hit me.
No one from my community
was in these pages,
and if they were missing,
then what else was lost?
So years later,
with infinite more questions,
I decided to make my own encyclopedia.
It's called the Encyclopedia
of Invisibility.
This is a 3,000-page,
leather-bound book
that has over 17,000 entries.
And yes, it was difficult,
but I read every single last one of them.
Now, the first entry that I wrote was on,
you guys may have guessed it,
the explorer Matthew Henson,
the one that I learned about
my first Arctic expedition.
From there, I thought, who and what else
should be included in these pages?
I would make list after list of things
that were excluded from history
and research them.
At first, it was just me alone.
Then I needed an assistant,
and then I needed an entire team.
And together we would comb
the globe looking for people,
places and things that were mostly untold.
Now this is arranged alphabetically,
and the organizing principle
was to try to include the kinds of things
that you may not ever learn at school.
So let's look at this entry on the Mino.
It's a powerful, all-female
military regiment
from the Kingdom of Dahomey,
which is current day Benin.
Then there's an entry on Robert Smalls.
Now the great Robert Smalls
freed himself from slavery,
overtook a bunch of Confederate ships,
freed a whole bunch of slaves
from those ships,
and then majestically marched on
to become one of the first
Black congressmen in the United States.
Then there's an entry on rhinoceros.
Did any of you know
there was a woolly rhinoceros?
No?
Then there's an entry
on Sister Rosetta Tharpe.
Sister Rosetta Tharpe is the mother
of all rock and roll.
Then there's an entry on B-movies.
Now who can't handle
a high-quality B-movie?
Then there's an entry
on the great John Edmonstone,
the man that taught
a very young Charles Darwin
the art of taxidermy and a whole lot more.
To come to think of it,
the only entry missing from this book
is an entry that explains how you can put
a full pair of socks into a dryer
and somehow only one foot comes out.
(Laughter)
Now, after 12 years,
a limited edition of this encyclopedia
was published as an artwork
occupying these territories
between sculpture, book and installation.
And this experience truly convinced me
that there are an infinite amount
of lost stories to be told,
and there's no real limits
to how they can be told.
So in 2014,
I decided to create an artwork
in honor of astronaut
Robert Henry Lawrence.
Now, Robert Lawrence
was the first Black astronaut.
He never realized his dream of space
as he was killed in a flight accident
in 1967 at the age of 32.
Now, my goal was to honor Robert
and to bring his profound legacy to space.
Now, those of you who know
anything about space,
you would know that that's
easier said than done,
because after all,
there ain’t a bunch of island folks
walking around with rockets
in their back pockets.
So step one was to find
someone with a rocket.
And who has rockets?
The head of SpaceX, Gwynne Shotwell.
And then I had to figure out
who was going to be
as interested in these
lost stories as I was.
The head of SpaceX, Gwynne Shotwell.
We were introduced by the LA County Museum
and after four years of rigorous
testing, planning and sculpting,
a satellite was produced
in honor of Robert.
Now, this satellite was made of gold,
and it was important for me
to have this satellite follow an ancient
Egyptian tradition of storytelling
by imbuing the essence
of a person into a container.
Now, this satellite was called Enoch,
after the story
of a mythological character
whose walk with the gods was so close
that he never, ever died.
On November 30, 2018,
Enoch blasted into space
in the belly of a SpaceX
Falcon 9 rocket into orbit.
Almost 50 years after his passing,
the legacy of Robert Henry Lawrence
is celebrated amongst the stars.
(Applause)
Now, I've spent my entire life
being obsessed with these lost stories.
Can these lost stories hold the key
that unlocks our sense of belonging?
Lost stories definitely need to be told.
Not in small ways.
But in ways that match the ambitions
of the people that we speak for.
Now, I know all of you
have access to lost stories,
so please,
let's not let them be lost forever.
Even if that means you're called
the pain in the butt
or a troublemaker.
And thank you.
(Applause)